welcome back whether you are healthy and
want to stay that way or fighting an
illness the drip rlv the sponsors of
this next segment have something for
everyone's personal health journey
hi my name is nathan atkins and i'm the
managing partner here for the drip car
las vegas my wife and i are the owners
of the drip bar
[Applause]
so the drip bar las vegas is an iv
infusion therapy center what we do is we
help maximize the benefit of cellular
health what that means is simply you
normally get your recommended daily
allowances we do maximize beneficial
allowances so cellular health is where
all your health begins and here at the
drip bar we provide ivs to keep you
healthy so vitamin infusion is very
important most people think you have to
be unhealthy to start with vitamin
fusion it's actually the opposite you
take vitamin infusion to enhance your
health so what we do is we help you stay
proactively healthy that minimizes and
reduces your health risks nathan thanks
for having us today so how many
different services do you guys offer
sure so we offer 16 different lifestyle
ivs we offer four health ivs and the
difference between health and lifestyle
is real simple sometimes people have
major maladies like cancer and we have
health things that support and serve
that we also have five different im
quick shots and so people say well
what's the difference between an iv and
a quick shot well the quick shot is
exactly that it goes right into the
gluteal muscle versus going into the
bloodstream obviously the iv in the
bloodstream is the most effective right
but we do have those two offers how does
the process work so the process starts
right here we take your vitals and once
we make sure you're healthy enough to
get an iv then we go back and we
actually make the ivs right on site so
i'm looking at the menu board of all the
different different drips that you have
and the one that jumps out to me the
energy boosting health support the power
pack well so everybody loves the power
pack so we call it energy in a bag right
so power pack is exactly that and it
also talks about the fact that it's
health support so it's going to give you
that energy a lot of people start to
lose that energy during the middle of
the day power packs to give them the
natural vitamins minerals and aminos
that they need to keep them active
throughout the day but it's also going
to boost their immune system all right
nathan why am i in the hot seat right
now well so among the other things that
we offer here we do blood testing
services right and so we discussed with
you vitamin d3 vitamin d3 is very vital
to your health and it's important to
know your levels and before we can give
you vitamin uh d3 shots we need to make
sure we understand where you are okay
and then we advise you as to what you
should or shouldn't do from that point
forward so what daniel's doing right now
is getting your vitals and then he's
gonna hook you up and take your blood
we're gonna send it off and within one
to two days we'll get your results back
and then you can tell me how much
vitamin d i need or how much vitamin d i
don't need or how much vitamin d you
don't need so that'll take a couple of
days i'll come back for those results
someone's watching right now they want
to come down and get an iv do you guys
have any special absolutely do so for
the very first iv session everyone
receives 25 off however we do a special
as well for military veterans first
responders and teachers they get fifty
percent off their first iv and then
veteran military first responders and
teachers always get a ten percent
discount forever that's awesome all
right thank you david you got it
thank you again to the drip rlv for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call
702-846-0851 or visit
ivylasvegas.com and again they have a
special offer locals receive 25 off
their first iv infusion they also offer
50 percent off for military veterans
first responders and also teachers